foreign
there was a phrase I used to hear a lot
my house is far from the center
I know nothing
a century ago this phrase was a tactic
for survival
when Soviet regime seized all of
Ukraine's crops and ruthlessly executed
anyone who opposed them families learned
that to survive
they need to stay far away from the
center
this mentality of knowing nothing and
doing nothing dates back before I was
born
but I got to see a change
I'm 12.
it's winter
mom comes home
and her cheeks are still Rosy from the
frost
she wears black shoes a black coat black
everything mom is a fashion icon
but I noticed something new and unusual
an orange ribbon proudly tied on her
wrist on top of her shiny black leather
gloves
the next day I noticed other people
wearing orange ribbons
after school my dad mom's sister and I
are all going to a Central Square of my
town nipro there are so many people too
many to count
I'm shocked
all of them wearing orange ribbons then
I noticed an elderly neighbor from
upstairs
the lady from the grocery store
and my algebra teacher
how how is this happening what are all
these people doing here it's so cold
outside did my mom start at all do I
still need to do algebra homework
orange Revolution became a turning point
when Ukrainian stood up for democracy
and overturned fraudulent election
results
one small action like wearing an orange
ribbon can lead to other small actions
and these actions together can spark a
big change
I learned this lesson at the age of 12.
and almost 20 years later I learned it
again
I heard about full-scale invasion of
Ukraine while being here at Stanford in
my dorm
half a world away
I was devastated
Russian tanks trouble rolled over the
Border
cities were on fire the airport where I
land when I go home destroyed
daily routine classes purpose all lost
purpose to me
Ukraine was everything I could think
about and there was nothing I could do
I felt helpless
I knew there were other ukrainians on
campus and my mind reminded me of orange
ribbons more than anything else I wanted
us to be together
I texted a Ukrainian WhatsApp group
if you feel an urge to be together come
to a huddled room
I've put a huge sticky note stand with
Ukraine on the door and brought cattle
for tea
for the first 30 minutes
I was in a room alone
in the sunny and warm Californian
afternoon
I felt cold and foreign
but then people started to show up
with their families friends even pets in
two hours the room was full of people
and ideas how we can help our Beloved
Country
what this group was able to achieve in
48 hours
first month and first year was nowhere
on my mind
today I want to share a few learnings
from that time that might help you when
you feel helpless
the day after Invasion our group of
about 15 ukrainians and our first allies
was working on a website it brought
together resources about war and
organizations through which people could
help
the next day we realized that fepsite is
visited globally and to get our message
far and wide we need to write in many
more languages
it was almost 11 at night but it didn't
stop our undergrads in a matter of
minutes they are texted their friends
and a dozen of international students
showed up to write in Arabic Czech
Portuguese Korean Chinese by the end of
the night we had 20 different languages
in when other challenges arose we found
an expert already in the room Among Us
or a good friend of someone in the room
if we shared our obstacles soon the
sooner we found person eager to be
helpful
my learning number one
ask for help early
in the next five days our group of
certainly ambitious but still just
students was juggling a variety of ideas
should we procure steel bulletproof
steel panels in Mexico or hack the
highly censored Russian internet
then
Josh walked in
American Ally veteran med school student
with an empty suitcase in one hand and
an airplane ticket in the other he said
I'm flying to Ukraine in two weeks help
me fill this suitcase with what is
needed most
with that suitcase
Josh brought us something intangible yet
crucial
he brought us clarity
we would fill a suitcase
and then someone told why can't we get
you a plane that's how the entire team
got a clear concrete imaginable idea of
filling the entire plane with
humanitarian health and medical supplies
next Josh and I recorded the video and
we collected half a million dollars to
Charter a plane that brought 32 tons of
medical supplies through Poland to
Ukraine
the story went viral
other classmates traveling to Ukraine
carried another almost a thousand pounds
of needed supplies soon large ngos
opened free routes to carry donated
medicine and medical supplies
my learning number two
set clear concrete and imaginable goals
and it helps if the goal is inspiring
now you may think that if you ask for
help early
and work on your clear goal things are
easy
but not quite
some of us were struggling
Andre
is a physics major
as and his favorite language is math and
equations
however when he shared statistics and
facts about the war
it didn't help his American friends to
understand how severe the situation is
in Ukraine he needed to try something
different
then he shared a story about his mother
and little brother who were sitting in
the bunker for the past month
and people responded
Andre
who was so shy he wouldn't let me take a
picture of himself was now speaking at
rallies from his heart
my learning number three be ready to
stretch to achieve your goals
fast forward our group of volunteers
brought over 5 million dollars worth of
medical supplies to Ukraine some of us
travel to Ukraine to bring medical
equipment ambulances and all kinds of
gear
undergrads launched a website that calls
out companies that still operate in
Russia med school students launched a
free telemedicine portal that provides
medical consultations and mental help to
hundreds of patients
I'm telling you all these stories for a
few reasons
I would love it if you donate to causes
in Ukraine
[Applause]
but you may have a cause of your own
addressing the climate change
reducing inequality
helping victims of turkey Syria
earthquake
whatever it is
you may feel far away from the center of
these issues
you may feel helpless
but in today's world we're all at the
center
ask for help early
set clear concrete and imaginable goals
be ready to stretch to achieve them
your small action
may lead to their small action
and together we are capable of a big
change
let's do something great together
[Music]